Do you have thoughts on ozone, especially home ozone units for daily rectal ozone?
So daily rectal ozone insulation can be really good for a lot of things.
You will absorb some of that ozone and ozone in your system can be beneficial for a lot of things.
Now, in, you know, we've had this discussion, you know, 50 times on the Zoom call.
I know this is probably a new person to ask you this question.
To me, ozone makes no sense what you're trying to kill a pathogen, not what you're trying to kill cancer.
So the ozone is O3.
So that's what ozone is.
So just understand the chemistry.
So ozone, so oxygen is is O2.
That's oxygen.
It's a stable molecule.
Oxygen is two electrons.
And so it's stable when it's connected to each other like that.
Ozone is O3.
It's an unstable molecule.
And because it's unstable, we could use it to its benefit.
So it will search for something to attach to it attaches to pathogens.
That's what ozone really in our environment.
Would you go out after a thunderstorm and you smell ozone and it smells so nice and fresh.
Really, that is God's way of cleaning the atmosphere.
So ozone is produced with, with, with light need.
So light need produces ozone.
The rain can pull ozone down from the ozone layer and it kills pathogens.
It helps kill mold in our environment of the world that you're walking in.
It can be very beneficial for you.
You could use an ozone machine in the air to help kill mold in your house.
You can kill mold underneath your blankets.
You can kill mold in a closet by putting the ozone machine in a closet.
I recommend people put an ozone machine in a musty, but in a musty basement.
I have an ozone machine in our office.
I have an ozone machine in our house.
My kids have ozone machines.
Now too much ozone can be damaging to the lung tissue.
So all these machines have a setting on it so it won't produce too much ozone.
So there are some machines out there that don't have that setting.
They're commercial use ozone machines and you do it to be more careful with them
because you could damage your lungs with too much ozone.
Now doing ozone the way this person is saying and using rectal ozone and using IV ozone,
what would that be used for?
It kills pathogens.
So if you have Lyme disease, if you have chronic mold, ozone can be beneficial for that.
Ozone will stimulate an inflammatory reaction too.
So you can actually inject ozone into a degenerative knee
and that can be beneficial for that.
But to kill cancer with ozone, I just don't know about that.
There's just not any data that shows that it's going to kill a cancer cell.
It doesn't kill your living cells.
I don't know how the mechanism, how it's going to kill your cancer cell.
So it's, you know, adding an oxygen, reactive oxygen species
to the tissue can actually cause cancer.
So using too much ozone internally,
now you won't absorb ozone if you're just breathing an ozone from an ozone machine.
So you're not getting an internal O3 that's breaking apart.
It's giving it a reactive oxygen species.
So a reactive oxygen species is cancer causing.
That is an oxidative reaction that can cause cancer.
So there's a difference between an oxidative reaction and oxygen.
So, so reactive oxygen species, ROS, is damaging to your cells.
So I don't see the benefit of using ozone personally.
And I'm not against somebody who feels like really you do ozone to kill cancer
and they feel like they've got results from that.
So I'm not making a judge will call that way.
I'm just giving you my opinion.
Yeah, I see ozone used, I see the success of ozone used from a clinical standpoint
if you're trying to kill pathogens.